in Brazil we think it was a leading man
your ladies man but you haven't actually
done that many love scenes no oh why is
that how is that no I just haven't had
the opportunity you know I've done a lot
of films where there's a lot guys the
director the director never directed I
love this yeah that's true
so awkward Kate Winslet step forward to
get quite bossy because so I've done a
few of these kinds of scenes before and
so we get there and pour honey our
director he's such a lovely man and he
was really quite nervous and he had an
extensive shot list and I'm thinking oh
my god we are absolutely never gonna get
all this done what kind of scene is this
anyway there's like 25 shots and an
interest was you were a little bit
nervous weren't you not really not okay
that was my game you know slowly and I'm
like right look okay we need to really
start filming this what's with all this
kind of chat and honey said actually you
know I'm really kind of nervous I've
never done this - actually never I
really haven't shot anything like this
before at all and interest said no and I
haven't done much of it either and I
went but the camera over there we're
gonna do this and we're gonna do that
and then interest said keep your socks
off and I'm like keep my socks off
everything else is off but I said no
I've got it I've got a foot thing got a
thing just
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you know very big feet and and they're
not particularly beautiful feet either I
shall keep on I shall keep inside the
shoes that they're in anyway so I'm
thinking what porridge doesn't want to
see him I think is maybe he just does
not like feet in general and that's the
whole thing it's the opposite ladies and
gentlemen Idris loves feet
[Applause]
wait to see this movie
[Music]